on va retrouver tout de suite nos deux
collègues des deux collines madeleine
blé morin qu'on retrouve à ottawa ces
bassins mauvais keita québec mon sens la
boudeuse pour forger commençons tout de
suite par les vaccins alors ça a été
dévoilée finalement mais beaucoup plus
segmentée qui sont les populations qui
vont être prioritaire on voit c'est
vraiment tranchées en lamelles très
fines
parce qu'il aura pas beaucoup de vaccins
au début madeleine ça va être tout un
défi pour le gouvernement parce que des
gens qui ont très très hâte de servex d
y en a qui ont nom qui ont très très
peur on le sait mais ce serait vraiment
du compte gouttes ce faire oui mais on
savait déjà qu'il y avait 6 millions de
doses qui serait disponible d'ici la fin
mars aussi suffisant pour vacciner trois
millions de personnes
et quand pour considère par exemple à la
population des personnes âgées de 65 ans
et plus on compte 7 millions de
personnes
donc il fallait avoir des sous
catégories des catégories très raffiné
pour que ce soit finalement pas trop
arbitraire mais quand même basé sur
certaines données scientifiques donc on
commence par les populations les plus
vulnérables celles qui habitent en foyer
de soins de longue durée dans des
résidences de personnes âgées le
personnel médical qu'on y va par tranche
d'âge les personnes de 70 ans et plus
mais même on commence même par les
personnes de 80 ans et plus on diminue
par tranche de cinq ans jusqu'à 70 ans
et plus parce que ce sont les gens qui
sont les plus susceptibles de f
inalement avoir des complications du
virus et peut-être même d'en mourir donc
tout ça même si on n'y va pas avec un
compte gouttes
ça va quand même allégé la pression sur
le système de santé parce que ce sont
justement les personnes les plus
vulnérables
donc le fait d'avoir vacciné trois
millions de personnes c'est peut-être
juste 10% de la population même moins
mais ça permet quand même un peu
d'oxygène dans le système de santé ça
c'est certain mais en parlant avec le
major le général major qui est en charge
tout ça monsieur fortin aujourd'hui ce
concombre hoeness et que son opération
extrêmement délicate dans ces bassins de
manutentionner ce vaccin parce que le
premier qu'on va avoir c'est la
compagnie pfizer alors il faut le même
temps ce youn et en laissant toujours
dans une chaîne de froid à moins 80
degrés donc ce sera un très très grand
déploiement au départ non et le canada a
beau être froid au mois de janvier on
est quoi ce point là donc s'arrêter
idéal genre 25
mais bon en effet et ça c'est très
important est sûre de mayom dans cette
chaîne de fabrication à sa part
évidemment de l'usiné ont produit le
vaccin jusqu'à l'injection dans le bras
de la personne qui reçoit le vaccin dit
entre les deux il ya les camions qui
transportent ça il ya l'aide les
entrepôts qui entreposent le vaccin est
ensuite les plis camions de l'entrepôt
vers les sites de vaccination
donc c'est une opération presque
militaire c'est pour la raison pour
laquelle c'est un militaire qui est en
charge de ça pour le canada et comme ils
vous le disais à partir de lundi va
faire des répétitions pour être prêt la
question c'est est roi quand est ce
qu'on va recevoir les premières doses de
vaccin pitt cei a encore floues là
dessus sur la date précise
en fait jusqu'à maintenant il ya
énormément de pression sur le
gouvernement trudeau madeleine la part
des partis d'opposition de la part des
provinces en fait tout le monde est
impatient et même des provinces qui
lançait déjà des dates alors que les
bacs ne se pose ne sont pas encore
confirmés à partir du moment où on va
commencer sur les réactions de
vaccination ça va être quoi le défi
politique pour monsieur trudeau est ce
que la pression va s'accentuer parce
qu'on va vouloir que ça aille plus vite
ou au contraire est-ce que ça va
soulager un peu de la pression bien deux
choses ça va soulager au début de
l'opération parce qu'on va pas voir
seulement des images d'anglais
d'angleterre en train de se faire
vacciner d'américains en train de se
faire vacciner de français alors que
nous on attend toujours
notre première livraison ce délai la il
est politiquement délicat quand même
pour le gouvernement trudeau
mais une fois que l'opération commence
c'est un autre test pour le gouvernement
est probablement un test encore plus
important parce que là on parlait de
cette chaîne de froid c'est tous ces
maillons qui doivent fonctionner on a
beau faire des répétitions à partir de
la semaine prochaine avec des fausses
boîtes si on veut le livret boîte vide
ça reste un défi logistique majeur
donc il faut pas qu'il y ait de chaînon
qui brisent parce que sinon ça risque de
d'occasionner évidemment des problèmes
donc c'est un texte énorme sur le
gouvernement fédéral et cette fois ci
c'est surtout le gouvernement fédéral
qui s'en charge
parce que jusqu'ici oui il ya de vue par
exemple aider les canadiens qui avaient
perdu leur emploi en leur envoyant
rapidement des chèques de prestations
canadiennes d'urgence par exemple mais
d'un point de vue médical
ça a beaucoup été un défi pour les
provinces cette fois ci le gouvernement
réalise que ça va être à son tour
finalement de devoir livrer la
marchandise là dans un terme propre et
figuré je vous ai envie je voulais
laisser passer juste un petit aparté
parce que les chiffres de l'alberta
viennent de sortir et on les attendait
avec impatience parce que c'est la
province qui en ce moment là est
vraiment sous la loupe parce qu'elle
crée de l'inquiétude
1807 nouveau corps aujourd'hui on
déplore 15 17 99 personnes sont aux
soins intensifs pour une province avec
vraiment une population qui est plutôt
petit comparé aux alentours de 4
millions en fait plus de personnes donc
la moitié à peu près de la population du
québec
sébastien bouwy vous aviez une idée je
vais quand même qu'on donne ces chiffres
là parce que je me demandais jusqu'à
quel point
ottawa va mettre de la pression sur
monsieur keddy pour vos séries peut-être
davantage encore ses mesures sanitaires
à notre collecte en tout nous expliquer
que les restaurants sont encore ouverts
les bars sont encore verts même si à
plus de restrictions ils resteront on
est loin d'un grand confinement le
voyait deux choses la pression sur
monsieur qu'est né aussi pour aller plus
loin il ya on a l'impression qu'il ya
une idéologie aussi de monsieur qu'est
né qui fait en sorte qu il veut pas
fermer les commerces donc il a il était
réticent aussi un bon événement celi
ville qui impose le masque en alberta
jusqu'à maintenant il est en discussions
avec ottawa pour avoir des hôpitaux de
campagne pour traiter les gens qui
arrivent dans les hôpitaux donc il ya
énormément de pression en alberta jeu
jusqu'à ajouté comme dans un conte
importance de la vaccination au pays
dans un contexte normal même si on peut
pas parler de normalité ici ce serait
déjà défis énormes gouvernement de
vacciner les canadiens rajoutez à ça que
monsieur trudeau songe peut-être à
déclencher des élections au printemps et
pour lui il faut que ça marche parce que
si ça marche pas les canadiens se
déclenche des élections pourraient le
juge
là dessus vous après l'empêcher
peut-être même de déclencher des
élections
si ça va mal alors on essaie d'imaginer
un contexte en pleine campagne de
vaccination une campagne électorale
c'est un petit peu d'écho serré et les
slaouis voilà mes wenzhou ya pas du
développement la laine de ce côté là en
fait c'est ce que nous dit le wall
street journal c'est pas tout ce que
nous dit monsieur trudeau parce que
manifestement il veut pas aborder ce
sujet là oui c'est très très très
délicat pour le canada même de parler de
ce qui se passerait entre le département
de la justice américain et les avocats
de maïwenn jouent alors petit retour en
arrière hier le wall street journal nous
dit qu'il y aurait des négociations
entre la haute dirigeante de huawei et
finalement le gouvernement américain
pour essayer de trouver genre d'entente
qui permettrait à main noir jo de
retourner en chine en échange de quoi
elles devraient admettre une certaine
culpabilité à des allégations faites aux
états unis entre autres madame gwangju
est accusé de fraude
donc ce serait une façon finalement de
lui permettre de rentrer et idéalement
là ce serait un trio on en négoce irait
en triangle idéalement pour avoir une
clause mycal ça ne le dit pas dans le
wall street journal aussi précisément
que ça mais évidemment du côté canadien
c'est ce qu'on souhaite que les deux me
colle plus entrer au canada puissent
revenir
eux qui vont être incarcérés depuis deux
ans la semaine prochaine c'est une
éternité et on sent qu'ils sont
finalement victime de tensions entre la
chine et les états unis et que le canada
s'est trouvé coincé entre ces deux
puissances la donc s'ils se passe
effectivement des négociations le canada
probablement est bien content mais il
reste encore beaucoup de bémols par
exemple mais one jo n'a pas encore
accepté de plaider coupable ou dire
qu'elle qu'elle admet une certaine
culpabilité donc déjà lost un problème
deuxième problème c'est que les chinois
ont toujours refusé de faire un lien
officiellement entre la détention madame
bendjo ici et la détention des deux me
colle donc admettons que madame mémoire
jo pu retourner en chine les chinois
voudront pas perdre la face en disant ok
retour reprenez vos de maicon
parce qu'ils ont toujours refusé
d'enterrer c'est tout une question de
sauver la face pour tout le monde c'est
madame georges reconnaître une part de
culpabilité josas pas fait c'est fait
partie du conte premiers s'ils sont
prêts à faire des compromis chacun doit
faire des compromis
la contrepartie de ce deal entre les
etats-unis et la chine et huawei
peut-être c'est l'épaule canada il faut
absolument que les deux michael soit à
l'intérieur de cette contrepartie on
n'accepterait pas je pense au canada qui
m'amène quittent le pays après avoir
fait une entente avec les états unis et
qui de michael reste en prison fait qui
pourrait être libéré un mois plus tard
il pourrait peut-être dans un délai
entre les événements mais il faut
absolument qu'il y ait une entente
michael ou une clause maiko dans cet
attentat trop bon mais vraiment on va
croiser les doigts pour eux on revient
sur noël sébacées file avance le 24
heures le conte de penser un peu le
moment du choc qui aura pas très simple
à noël parce que la nouvelle a été
donnée hier par monsieur legault 24
heures plus tard est ce que c'est une
bonne chose finalement de la part de
monsieur le goût de le dire tout de
suite de dire avant la date qu'il avait
donné au départ comme date butoir le 11
décembre oui parce que ça a été le
supplice de la goutte fallait pas être
un doctorat en santé publique pour
comprendre que la tendance n'était pas
favorable ne faisait pas en sorte que
c'était faisait en sorte que c'était pas
c'était plus judicieux d'avoir des
rassemblements annuels alors monsieur
legault conquis par reconnu pour sa
patience s'est impatienté puis il a dit
je mets un terme à ça sans même avoir la
recommandation formelle de la santé
publique
on présume que la santé publique dans
une semaine aurait recommandé
l'annulation des rassemblements noël en
zone rouge mais c'était la décision à
prendre pour monsieur legault et
maintenant il peut se concentrer sur
d'autres choses maintenant c'est passé
en fait il doit se concentrer sur deux
choses s'assurer qu'il ya toujours de
l'adhésion aux mesures aux consignes
sanitaires
parce que la question c'est de savoir si
les gens vont respecter les directives
qui ont été données par le gouvernement
et par le premier ministre la deuxième
chose sur laquelle doit se concentrer si
la vaccination c'est un lueur au bout du
tunnel pour s'assurer que ça fonctionne
au québec
vous nous ramener sur le terrain de la
vaccination est-ce que vous avez
l'impression ça va être un gros défi
parce qu'on a vu ce sondage qui est
produit par produit là du canada cette
semaine sur l'adhésion la volonté des
canadiens madeleine de se faire vacciner
il reste quand même que je reste
sans cela il ya une poche de résistance
mais il ya quand même une majorité de
canadiens qui semble être prêt à être
vaccinés mais il ya aussi une porte une
bonne proportion des jets les chiffres
devant moi qui 38% qui attendrait un ou
deux mois avant de se faire vacciner et
tout à l'heure on parlait de la pression
sur le gouvernement trudeau
d'une certaine façon que des canadiens
disent nous on veut pas nécessairement
avec les toutous tout premiers à se
faire vacciner
peut-être que ça enlève un peu de
pression sur justin trudeau sur son
gouvernement de faire les choses
correctement de laisser le temps à santé
canada de les approuver ces vaccins la
de les distribuer aux populations les
plus vulnérables d'abord comme si les
canadiens ne sont pas tous pressés de se
mettre dans une longue longue longue
longue file pour se faire vacciner les
premiers donc il va peut-être y avoir
finalement un set certaines ordre qui va
pouvoir se produire de cet incident il
disait que la seule bonne nouvelle de ce
fait vacciner peut-être après d'autres
pays c'est de voir ce qui va se passer
dans les autres pays avec les effets
secondaires du vaccin avant qu'ils ne
soient injectés dans les bras des
canadiens ici évidemment du cynisme plus
sur quatre mais plusieurs médecins qui
pensent comme ça quand même à brax alors
bas le royaume uni la prudence plutôt du
cynisme d'accord alors que je pense trop
de temps sur la colline parlementaire
la part de différents experts
c'est une bonne chose que ça commence
ailleurs ça nous permet de voir venir un
peu ce qui va se passer plus de regarder
si tout le monde va bien après ça ce
sera le monde le fait merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nouvelle femme ce
week-end paroisse